it is an honor to win this award and I
do disagree a little bit with all due
respect with Ricky I think we should use
our platform for good because we are
civilized human beings most people are
lepers they're absolute lepers and I'm
not and you can don't you know and
that's why you don't touch them I have
tried to bring dance to the inner city
for years and and dancing ballet not
like that violent dance they do were
there
they're almost fighting anyway but at
the end of the day I look at other
people and I say how are you a lot you
walk into an Applebee's and you see
these people eating chicken wings and
you say to yourself there but for the
grace of God go on so the reality is it
is our job to help these beasts litter
literally beasts and we're supposed to
civilize and our foundation just goes
around the inner city and gets people to
talk a little quieter let's just start
there we start there you start there
with just a little quieter and and you
tell me I haven't been to the real world
I've been to Chicago and I am sat down
with poor minorities that did not have a
lot of money Barack and Michelle Obama
and I helped them I want to thank my
father who ran Paramount Pictures for
many years I love you dad it wasn't easy
but we did it together
thank you thank you I built it on my own
it's all on my own thank you
[Applause]